SRINI DEVADAS: Good
morning, everyone.
Thanks for making it here
through the snow and sleet.
You will be, quote
unquote, rewarded
with a cool little puzzle that
has both recreational value as
well as a deep connection to the
most popular sorting algorithm,
or at least the most commonly
used sorting algorithm,
called quicksort.
And so what we have
up here is what
I call the disorganized
handyman puzzle.
This is not a puzzle
of my invention,
but I called it this because
I think at some point
when I read this, it
was a carpenter who
had a bunch of nuts
and bolts in his bag,
and they were all mixed up.
So rather than having these
nuts attached to the bolts,
he was disorganized and the
nuts and bolts were separate.
And then they all got
mixed up together in a bag,
OK?
Now, obviously, all puzzles
are a little bit contrived.
And so we're going
to assume here
that there's 100 different
nuts and 100 associated bolts.
And these 200 objects are all
mixed up into this one bag
that the carpenter is carrying.
And not only that,
each of the bolts
is unique in terms of its size.
And as I mentioned, there is
an associated nut associated
with each unique bolt. And
so, as you can imagine,
the goal of this puzzle
is going to be finding
the most efficient
way of creating
some organization in
this bag by attaching
each nut to the corresponding
bolt, or vice versa.
And you can assume that
there's no ambiguity because
of the uniqueness of
the nuts and the bolts.
And there's 100 pairs
waiting to be discovered.
And you can try to
make that process as
efficient as possible.
As with all of the puzzles
that we look at here,
there's going to be naive slash
straightforward way of doing
this.
You're going to go ahead and
figure that out pretty quickly.
We're going to analyze
the complexity of that,
or how long it takes for
a specific example of 100
nuts and 100 bolts,
and then we're
going to scratch our heads and
try and do better, all right?
And as I mentioned,
obviously, there's
going to be some programming
associated with this.
And we're not going to
represent nuts and bolts
in programs or codes.
We're going to switch gears and
talk about sorting once we're
done with this puzzle.
Good.
The only way that
you or the carpenter,
if you're the
carpenter's helper,
have of checking to see that
a nut attaches to a bolt
is to try it out.
And the nuts and bolts are
different enough in size
that even if you had
your eyes closed or it
was a dark room, if the
nut attaches to the bolt,
it would screw on perfectly.
If the bolt is smaller than the
nut, it would just go through
and it would be obvious that the
bolt is smaller than the nut.
And if the nut is
smaller than the bolt,
it would also be obvious
because the bolt won't
go through it, which
makes perfect sense
from a physical
standpoint, right?
And you all tried this before.
We've had-- maybe
not all of you,
but I've certainly had
occasion to discover
pairs of nuts and bolts, though
it was never 100 of them.
So that's kind of a little
bit contrived, as I said.
All right, good.
So the setup is clear?
We're good on the setup?
Excellent.
So what is the straightforward
way of doing this?
Someone.
Yeah, Fadi back there.
AUDIENCE: So like
choose a nut by random
and try every
different bolt in turn.
SRINI DEVADAS: Right, we
could choose a nut at random,
try every different bolt,
or choose a bolt at random
and try every different nut.
And we're guaranteed, in this
case, that there is a pairing.
And so after we do that, we can
put this paired nut and bolt
aside and we've shrunk
the problem down to one
less than the original problem.
If I started out with 100 pairs
that are not paired together,
but there's 100
nuts and 100 bolts,
then I get one pair
which is a correct pair,
and I have 99 nuts
left and 99 bolts left.
And I keep going.
Perfectly reasonable
way of doing things.
And let me show you
how that would work.
These slides were made by
my daughters many years ago
you know, back when
they listened to me.
I have a fat chance of getting
them to do any work for me
anymore.
But they are busier than they
were, I guess, years ago.
At least they pretend to be.
And there you go.
You end up, in this particular
example, which obviously
has many fewer than
100 nuts and bolts,
you end up checking this.
And in the worst case,
how many comparisons
would I have had to do if I
had 100 nuts and 100 bolts?
In the worst case,
I would have to--
AUDIENCE: Do all 100.
SRINI DEVADAS: I
have to do all 100,
because I might just
have gotten unlucky.
Like I said, we're not
eyeballing this at all.
You could probably prune
the search a little bit
with respect to putting aside--
not having to do an
exact comparison.
But let's just say
that even looking
at a nut, as opposed
to even touching it
with the bolt that
you've chosen,
is, in fact, a comparison.
You're just eyeballing it
as opposed to physically
touching the bolt
and nut together,
and we're going to
call that a comparison.
And if you do that, and if
you make that assumption, then
obviously, you're going to
have to look at all 100 nuts
if you have a random bolt,
in the worst case, OK?
You might get lucky.
On an average, it
might be only 50.
We're not going to do that
type of analysis here.
So that's good.
And what is the complexity
in terms of the growth rate
of this particular algorithm?
If I had N nuts
and bolts, then I
do N comparisons in the worst
case, to find the first pair.
And when I say first pair,
I mean the correct pairing
that's associated with
the nut and the bolt.
And what happens-- yeah,
Kevin, you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't it
be less than N squared,
because once you find each
pair, you have one less?
SRINI DEVADAS:
That's exactly right.
It's absolutely less than N
square in terms of numerics.
The growth rate is a slightly
different question, right?
It's related, obviously.
And so if you do this and
you get the first pair,
you now have a problem that
is of size N minus 1, right?
And so in this case,
how many comparisons
am I going to make when
I have N minus 1 nuts
and N minus 1 bolts,
in the worst case?
I'm going to do N minus
1 comparisons, right?
And then I keep going down.
And you could argue
that at the very end,
when I have two nuts and
two bolts, one comparison,
if I assume that this was a
perfect set of nuts and bolts,
that we had all pairs
right at the beginning,
you could argue that that
small problem corresponding
to two nuts and bolts can be
solved using one comparison.
And you immediately know which
nut pairs with which bolt,
and the other one as well.
But let's call it a
confirmation comparison,
and essentially say you need two
comparisons here and one here.
You can obviously shave a
number a little bit out of this.
But this goes back to--
Kevin is right.
It's less than N square if
you look at it numerically.
But the growth rate is
N square, because we
know that N plus N
minus 1 plus N minus 2,
dot dot dot, 2 plus 1 is N
times N plus 1 divided by 2.
And sure, you could
take this 1 off
and this would become N
times N minus 1 divided by 2,
but that growth
rate is N square.
Grows as N square.
So if you had 100 nuts
and hundreds bolts,
you're talking about something
of the order of 5,000
comparisons if you want
to do it numerically.
And it grows as N squared.
If you had 1,000,
then it would be
1,000 times 1,000,
which is 1 million,
divided by 2, that's 500,000.
So that is astronomical
in terms of its growth.
You don't want to do that.
Obviously a contrived problem,
but N square in general,
when you talk
about manual labor,
is generally not very good.
So we'd like to improve this.
And we've been talking
about recursion.
We've been talking about
divide and conquer.
This is not divide and
conquer in the true sense
in that you're going to a
smaller problem, admittedly.
But recall I said,
divide and conquer
is usually used when
you break the problem
up into fractional pieces,
which means in mergesort,
for example, we took--
or the tiling puzzle, we took
courtyard and we broke it up
into four courtyards.
So essentially, we
had four quarters
in the case of
the tiling puzzle.
We had two halves in
the case of mergesort.
Here we are solving,
basically, one nut and bolt
in the original puzzle.
And then we're going
from N to N minus 1,
and so there's many
more steps, right?
The one thing to remember when
you think about complexity
is that when you go N to N
divided by 2 to N divided by 4,
and then you keep going,
and you go all the way down
to 1, this, of course,
when you go like this,
there's a linear
number of steps.
But when you do
that, how many steps
do you have to get all
the way to 1 in relation--
if you start with N, how
many steps do you have?
If this were 64--
or let's just take
a simpler one.
If this were 4, how
many steps would I have?
I would have two steps.
If this were 8, I'd
have three steps.
And so what's that formula?
AUDIENCE: Logarithm.
SRINI DEVADAS: Logarithm.
Log to the base 2, right?
So that's the power
of fractional sizes.
And this is actually a
very fundamental notion
that is going to appear
over and over if you
do any algorithms work or
take any algorithms classes.
That divide and conquer
is very efficient,
because the number of
steps in order to get down
to small problems
is relatively small.
It's a logarithm.
Now, if you broke this
up into three parts
and you went to
N/3, et cetera, then
this would be log to
the base something else,
log to the base 3.
So log to the base 2 came
because we broke it up
and we went down
to half the size.
Now remember, of
course, I mean, it's
not that the complexity
here is just logarithmic.
It's that you do
have two problems.
This is a function of the
particular specific algorithm
that corresponds to
divide and conquer.
But in the case
of mergesort, it's
not that we just
went from N to N/2--
well, we went from N to N/2,
but there were two N/2 size
problems.
But the beauty of
divide and conquer
is if I magically broke
up the N sized problem--
and let's go back
to nuts and bolts--
into two problems
of size N/2, so
each problem has N/2 nuts
and N/2 bolts, each problem--
I'll repeat that-- N/2 nuts
and N/2 bolts, then if I used--
and this is magical, right?
I don't quite know
how to do that yet.
But if I did that, then think
about what happens with respect
to these comparisons.
So I said when N was 100,
I needed 5,000 comparisons
for this naive algorithm.
But now if I did this and I
got two N/2's, then I have 50,
so I call that M equals 50.
And then I have another
one which is M equals 50.
And so roughly how
many comparisons would
I need if I had, as problem of
size 50, 50 nuts and 50 bolts,
using our original
naive strategy?
Roughly?
AUDIENCE: 1200
SRINI DEVADAS: 1,225, right?
Roughly.
And this would be 1,225.
And so, so that is 2,500.
So of course, I haven't quite
told you how to do this.
This is still magic.
But I was upfront about it.
But clearly, I've
gotten an improvement
if I have this magic, OK?
And so let's talk about that.
Let's turn this nuts and
bolts puzzle, or the solution
to this puzzle, and try
and figure out a divide
and conquer strategy
which is distinctly
different from the brute
force strategy that
just reduced by one, all right?
Now, we'll-- this
is just going on.
So the comparisons in the
worst case is what I just said.
And it grows as N square.
So big O N square means
it just grows as N square.
That's asymptotic notation
that we won't go into,
but you understand
what that means now.
So if I do a
straightforward divide
and conquer, like I
did with mergesort,
where I just took the
array and I split it
in half, if I take
these nuts and bolts
and I separate the nuts out,
and I put 50 on this side, 50
on the other side,
take the bolts,
put 50 on this side and
50 on the other side,
is that going to work?
No, that's not going to work.
And the reason is if I do this
arbitrary partition, then--
and let's say that I take
this, and the two of you
get together, you're
friends and partners,
and you say, let's do this in
parallel and save some time,
you're still going
to be counting
the number of comparisons.
And so, obviously,
you also would
like to reduce the
number of comparisons.
But you can't even use a
helper here in the sense
that if you split
this up-- obviously,
this was not 50 and 50,
but three nuts and three
bolts on one side and four
and four on the other side.
As you can see
from this example,
you had a situation where the
matching nut was in one pile
on the left for a bolt that
was on the right-hand side.
And that could happen
not just for one,
which would kill the
process, but could
happen for many nut-bolt pairs.
So we can't do that.
We cannot use the
straightforward divide
and conquer approach.
So this comes to the
first interesting question
that we have here, which is, how
do we exploit the fact that all
of you are going to help me?
So I'm the disorganized
carpenter or handyman.
And I'd like to break this
up, first into two piles, such
that I can go off and send
one or more of you off
and say, OK, I can guarantee
that this is a subproblem,
in the sense that the
original problem had
all of the bolts that
matched all of the nuts that
were in my pile.
I want to break it up
into two problems in--
this is the magic that we have.
We need to figure
out this magic--
such that if I give you
50 nuts and 50 bolts,
and I keep 50 nuts
and 50 bolts, that you
can solve that problem.
It is a problem.
I mean, there's a
matching there, right?
For those 50 nuts, you have
the 50 bolts in your pile.
Same thing with me.
So how do I do that?
Yeah, go ahead, Josh.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Can you compare the size
of nuts to each other?
SRINI DEVADAS: No, you cannot.
Yeah, good question.
So the only thing you
can do is you have a nut
and you have a bolt,
and if it goes through,
then the nut is bigger.
If it doesn't, then
the bolt is bigger.
And then if it fits exactly,
you have a match, all right?
Great, so yeah,
go ahead, Ganatra.
AUDIENCE: So once
you get one to fit,
you can use that to sort of
like order the other ones.
Because it fits in
perfectly, right, it fits,
so all the ones that-- you
just go through all of them,
and if it goes
through just the hole,
then you know
those are smaller--
well, they're bigger.
And then if it
doesn't fit through,
then you know that those--
SRINI DEVADAS: Right, great.
Excellent.
So Ganatra has discovered
this notion of pivoting.
And pivoting is
essentially something
that is best described here in
the animation that gives you
a divide and conquer strategy.
Now, I answered Josh's question,
and that was a key question.
And I'm not going to violate
the answer to that question
by using some other strategy
that does not correspond
to this nut-bolt check, right?
So the only thing I
can do in this puzzle
is a nut-bolt check.
But I do get three
potential possibilities
whenever I do a nut-bolt check.
I do get the information
about a perfect match,
whether the nut is smaller,
or whether the nut is bigger.
And that's all I need in
order to do pivoting, right?
And so what's going to
happen here is I go ahead
and I choose an arbitrary
bolt. And I don't even
actually need to find the match
before I start this process.
So it's a small variant
on what Ganatra said,
but it's really a
pretty small variant.
And when I see that
this is not a match,
and in fact, the nut is
bigger, then I put the nut
on the right-hand side pile.
When I see that
the nut is smaller,
then I put the nut in
the left-hand side pile.
And I see a match, I
just put that aside.
I don't put it in
either of the piles,
because I'm going to
actually-- it turns out
I'm not going to get a pile
of 50 and 50, or in this case,
I'm actually going to get
something like three and three,
because I'm going to
get one match out of it.
So in general, I'm
not necessarily
going to get equal size piles.
So that's actually a
little bit of an issue,
and we'll get back
to that maybe later.
But I will get a
matching, and I'll
get a pile on the left that
is the perfect problem,
perfect subproblem.
There I can hand it
off to any of you
and you can go off and
solve it and it will work.
And I'll get a pile on the
right, same thing for that.
So this was a match,
but I don't stop.
I don't put the nut in
either of the two piles.
It's just going
to stay up there.
And then I keep going.
And I make up my right
pile and my left pile.
Now, I'm not quite done yet.
What do I do now?
Yeah, back there.
AUDIENCE: You would test
every screw into that nut
to see which one--
SRINI DEVADAS: That's right.
So remember, I kept the--
I guess you used a
different term here.
You used-- I said
bolt, you said screw.
That's fine.
But we're talking
about a nut here.
So let's go with the nut.
And this nut that
I put aside, I'm
going to now compare that, not
with this pivot bolt that I
picked, which is now set aside
and never have used that again,
but I'm going to put
that aside, and I'm
going to compare each of the
bolts with this pivot nut
that I have.
So the pivot bolt was
picked and I discover
the associated pivot nut.
And now I'm going to use
that pivot nut, which
is the nut that I have up
here, the light green one,
and then I'm going
to do the same thing.
And all of this does not violate
the answer to Josh's question.
And it's going to do
exactly the right thing
in terms of giving
me two piles that
are beautiful problems that
are going to be solvable.
There's nothing that's stopping
me from repeating this process.
When we talk about
divide and conquer,
usually we talk about
recursion, and we
talk about repeatedly
doing divide and conquer.
Then I wrote this up here in
terms of the N size problem
turned into two N/2 problems.
Well, each of those
N/2 problems I
could turn into
two N/4 problems,
so I could have four N/4's,
and so on and so forth.
And so I could clearly do that.
And especially if
N is large, then I
want to get a reduction
in comparisons.
And get this to
grow, by the way.
And we won't do this analysis.
But rather than
growing as N square,
you'd like it to
grow as N log N.
And that's kind of the
asymptotic analysis
that you'll have to do if
you take a class like 6006.
But the general sense that
you should take away from this
is that you're going to have
a logarithmic number of steps.
And obviously, that doesn't
imply a logarithmic number
of comparisons, because the
number of subproblems in each
of those steps is doubling.
Initially, you had a problem,
then you have two subproblems,
and then you have
four subproblems.
Each of them are small
in size, but together,
assuming these problems
are N/2 and N/2, then
you can get something that's
substantially smaller than N
square, namely N log N, OK?
And you can do that numerically.
And I don't want to
get into that too much,
but be happy to talk to you
about this after lecture
or during office hours.
There's a couple of caveats.
One of them is there's
no guarantee here
if I pick a random pivot
bolt that I'm actually
going to get N/2 and N/2.
It's going to be
one less than that.
Maybe it'd be in over
N/2 and N over 2 minus 1.
I could get something-- if
I picked a large pivot bolt,
I might get a very skewed
pair of piles, right?
One of them could
have 80 in them--
80 nuts and bolts in
them, and the other one
could have 20 nuts
and bolts in them, OK?
So that's something
to worry about.
We won't worry about that.
But we'll talk about
it when we move
to sorting, which is
what we're going to do
in just a couple of minutes.
So people buy the solution
to the nuts and bolts puzzle.
Clearly, it's going to
give you some efficiency.
If you pick a
middling size bolt,
maybe you can eyeball that.
It's a little bit of a violation
of what we've talked about,
but you could clearly--
I mean, let's assume
that you can make out
the difference between
something that's as
thick as this and that finger.
And then you pick
something in the middle.
And then you can
get two large piles
that are roughly equal in size
from the original really large
pile.
And at least at
the beginning, you
could probably
get, in the context
of this puzzle, piles that
are roughly similar in size.
And after that,
it doesn't really
matter once you've
broken things up.
So N is not 100, but N
is more like 5 or 10.
At that point, it doesn't really
matter what strategy you use,
because the numbers aren't
really different, regardless
of the strategy.
So good, all right.
So I promised you a
relationship to sorting.
And obviously, we want to
do some programming here.
And it turns out
that just like we
had mergesort,
which was a divide
and conquer out
algorithm, it turns out
this pivoting strategy turns
into a strategy for divide
and conquer that is quite
different from mergesort,
but is equally applicable
to sorting numbers.
And so let me remind
you what mergesort was.
And then I'm going
to contrast mergesort
with quicksort, which is a
pivot-based sorting algorithm.
So forget about nuts and bolts.
We're now down to boring
numbers, integers.
And we want to just sort these
numbers in ascending order.
So if I have a bunch
of numbers and I
want to sort these in ascending
order, mergesort would say,
I'm going to go ahead and
break it up into halves.
And let's just do one
level of recursion.
With all of these things
you can always do more,
but these problems
aren't large enough
that you really want to
do that in this example.
And the important thing is
you just broke it into half.
But it was easy.
The split was easy.
You slice the list, splice
the list, what have you.
And you assume that
somehow you can sort this
in ascending order.
And in this case, you
need to go to that.
And then you sort this
in ascending order.
So you go like that.
And then you need to do a merge.
And we used what we call the
two finger algorithm to do
the merge that
essentially says, I'm
going to assume that
this array is sorted
and this array is
sorted, and I'm
going to put pointers up at the
beginning of these two arrays.
And I'm going to do comparisons.
And I'm essentially
going to assume
that I have a blank array of
size six, blank list of size
six.
And I'm going to be writing
into this blank array
the result of the comparison
that is, which one is
less in the comparisons.
So I'm going to get minus 31.
And then I compare
0 with minus 4,
and I'm going to get minus
4, 0, et cetera, et cetera.
So that was our merge.
And the important
thing to remember
is that our merge algorithm
had an easy divide step,
and it had a more
difficult step that
corresponded to taking the
subarrays that were sorted,
and the work was
all in the merge,
putting the things together.
Because the divide,
obviously, is just like chop.
Now, as you can see
from the nuts and bolts,
division was non-trivial, right?
Division required pivoting.
But there was no real
merge after that.
And one side handed off,
let's say, to Ganatra
these 50 nuts and bolts after
I did the work in pivoting.
And I kept 50 nuts
and bolts as well.
We were done.
I mean, maybe I wanted
the nuts and bolts back.
I don't want him to
run away with it.
But it wasn't like I
had to process anything
that he gave me back, right?
If he paired them
up, then I didn't
have to process that, right?
So this is mergesort.
The quicksort algorithm, which
I'll now describe to you,
is divide and conquer,
two-way divide and conquer,
same as mergesort, but it
kind of flips the work.
And it does more work up
front before the division,
and then this little
or no work at the end.
So what happens here is--
the way we're going to
think about quicksort
is we're going to
choose a pivot.
You can have some array here.
And I can go ahead and just
call these a, b, c, d, e, f, g.
And I'm going to choose a pivot.
And in the code that
I'm going to show you,
we're just going to go ahead
and choose the last element.
We assume that this
is in random order.
We're going to choose the
last element of this array
as the pivot.
And what did we do with
the pivot back in our nuts
and bolts example?
We-- someone, what did
we do with the pivot?
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: We spliced around it.
SRINI DEVADAS: Yeah, you just
basically spliced around it.
You compared it with--
we took the pivot bolt, and
in this case of the puzzle,
you compared it with the nuts.
Here we don't have nuts and
bolts, we just have numbers.
And so you're going
to take that pivot
and you're to start comparing
it with the other numbers.
And you're exactly right in that
we're going to get to the point
where we have to
splice round it,
which isn't your
standard Python splicing,
because that requires
contiguous locations.
But what you want to do is
you want to get to a situation
where you have something
like this, where you have
g somewhere in the
middle and all elements
less than g are to the left.
And let's assume they're
all unique elements.
All elements greater than
g are to the right, OK?
So this is exactly
pivoting around g.
So it's referred to
as pivoting around g.
Now, the nice thing
here, when you do this,
is that you can go off and
you can fix the location of g.
In fact, g's location,
just like the pair,
the nut-bolt pair was
corresponding to the pivot nut,
and the pivot bolt was
determined during the pivoting
step.
And you never had
to check whether--
you never had to
discover that pair again.
You can put that pair aside.
The location of g,
the pivot chosen,
in the final sorted
array, is determined
by this pivoting step, OK?
That makes sense?
And so this location,
whatever that index is,
it might be right in the middle.
It might be a little bit skewed.
But that location is determined.
And if you did this with roughly
equal piles, if you will,
or equal sides, if there
were 100 elements here,
you might see 50-odd here
and 40-odd over there.
Now, of course, if g happened
to be the largest number,
then g would be all
the way to the right.
So there's that to worry about.
But this is the divide step.
So the divide step
is the pivoting step.
And then you can go off and
sort each of those sublists.
Because those less
than g are not
necessarily in ascending order.
You just dumped them.
There's still work to be done.
And then the greater
than g, likewise.
They're not necessarily
in ascending order.
But you know that there's
42 elements corresponding
to less than g, and you
can go sort that array.
And those are going
to be the first 42
elements of your final array.
And the g is going to
be at the 43rd position.
And then the ones that are
greater than g are going
to be to the right of that.
All make sense?
Yeah, go ahead, Fadi.
AUDIENCE: So like if we were
very unlucky and at each step,
we just picked the largest
number, the largest
number, then it's
got to be N squared, correct?
SRINI DEVADAS: That's right.
So that's pathological.
Now, it turns out that,
amazingly, in order
to avoid that
situation when people
use quicksort in practice, which
is essentially this algorithm
that I describe, they take
the array that they're given
and they actually randomize it.
They actually make it--
they shake it up.
It's like you get
these nuts and bolts,
and you want to close
your eyes and you
want to pick up a nut
that's middling in size,
and maybe all the small
ones are up at the top
and the big ones are
down at the bottom.
You want things in
the middle, so you
go, you shake, shake, shake.
You randomize.
And then go stick
your hand in About.
Halfway through the
pile and pick up a nut,
or pick up a bolt, right?
That's kind of
what happens here.
So quicksort, it turns out--
and I'll just say this, and
if this doesn't make sense,
ask me later.
But it should give
you some intuition.
The randomized quicksort, where
you have this random input,
and you have some probabilistic
guarantee that you're
picking a pivot that is middling
in size in terms of an integer
size, is going to be
N log N in complexity.
But the worst case
complexity of quicksort
is exactly as you
said, it's N square.
But that's really not
something that you
need to understand deeply
to understand, well,
either the puzzle or the
rest of this lecture.
You do get a sense of--
as long as you have a sense
of if you pick something
in the middle and these piles
are roughly equal in size,
I'm going to get
some improvement.
The guarantee that
the piles are roughly
equal in size, all the way down
to the depths of recursion,
is a difficult one to achieve
in a deterministic way.
But it's not hard to achieve
in a probablistic way
by doing this randomization.
You had another question?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So then why do we
use this more than mergesort,
which is like--
SRINI DEVADAS: Ah,
that's exactly-- so
that is the rest of the lecture,
which is only 10 minutes left.
But OK, so that's the
rest of the lecture.
So one of the things
that I said here,
I said a blank list of size six.
So what mergesort requires,
in order for mergesort
to be efficient, you
needed auxiliary storage
that corresponded to
the size of the list.
Because right at the
first level of recursion,
when you got two arrays
that were N/2 and N/2,
and they were both sorted,
and you had to merge the two
together to create the
final result corresponding
to the sorted
array, you ended up
requiring storage
that was N in size
in order to actually do
this two finger algorithm
and compare the minus
31's with the zeros
and then write them
into this array.
Now, the obvious way of
taking this and going to here
is code that I'm going to show
you that is easy to write.
And it requires a
blank list as well.
I mean, the easy
way to do that--
and I'll just show you the
code, because it's easier
to show you the code as
opposed to waving my hands here
and potentially
confusing people.
But let me show you first the
quicksort divide and conquer,
which is absolutely trivial.
I mean, just like mergesort was.
But pivot partition
is this step here.
This is the pivoting step.
And this is what
that procedure does.
So we'll get to that
in just a second.
But the rest of it is simply
I'm going to go ahead,
and once I do the
pivot partition,
I have something
that looks like this.
And then I just go off
and run quicksort on this
and quicksort on that.
And I'm doing that
on the array itself.
It's just like I
have this array,
and I'm just saying I'm
going to call quicksort
with the indices
that are associated
with the beginning and
the end of this array.
And then I'm going
to call quicksort
with the indices that begin
with the beginning and the end
of this array.
And that same array is going
to be my final output, right?
So everything is done--
the term that's used
here is "in place."
So in place sorting
and insertion
sort, which is also N square,
and a few other things
are in place sorting algorithms,
which essentially say, look,
I need to sort all
of you in some way,
perhaps by age or something.
And I don't want
another room, right?
I don't want to say,
who's the youngest here,
and then go over to
that room, and then
who's the next youngest and go
over to the room, et cetera.
I just want you to start
swapping positions here.
And we're all going
to be in this room,
and somehow we're
going to get sorted.
So that's in place.
And when I have an array
that corresponds to integers,
I don't want another
blank list or blank array
and use that storage.
And so that answers
your question
at the top level as to
why quicksort is used.
And it's used because the
memory requirements of quicksort
are substantially
less than the memory
requirements of mergesort.
And in fact, you can
do this pivoting step
using one integer as storage.
You need the original
array, of course,
but you needed that to
store all of the numbers.
And the auxiliary storage, the
extra storage that you need,
is exactly the storage
for one integer
where you store the pivot, OK?
And I'm going to show
you the naive way, which
is the regular quicksort.
And that is a trivial
pivot partition.
It's not the clever one,
which essentially says,
look, I'm going to
go ahead and I'm
going to create a new array.
In fact, I have two arrays
that are less and more,
or two lists.
Together the sizes
of less and more
are going to be the size of
the original, maybe minus 1.
I'm adding to less
and adding to more,
depending on whether the
element is less than the pivot
or greater than the pivot.
And then I'm good.
So there's that algorithm,
which would just be, oh yeah,
I'm going to create
a new list here.
And I'm going to compare a to g.
And then I'm going to compare
b to g, et cetera, et cetera.
So this does not
give you anything.
This is an
uninteresting algorithm.
I'm sorry.
Implementation-- this is an
uninteresting implementation,
OK?
It is much more--
you need to be
much more clever--
I don't need this anymore--
to do this in place.
So what I want to do is I'm
going to take an example here.
I want to take this array.
And I'm going to not
talk about the recursive
sorting or anything like
that, because that's easy.
We kind of know how to do that.
What I want to do is I want
to choose this as the pivot.
And I want to
translate that somehow
into the final
pivoted output, which
is going to be 0,
minus 31, 1, 2, 65, 99.
Oops, I have
something wrong here.
So this should be
the other way around.
83, right?
OK.
Mm, bug.
Oh, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
This is fine.
I just need it--
I don't need it to be sorted.
OK, good.
Whew.
All right.
I just thought I found
the first bug in my book.
So there's probably
many bugs in the book,
but I don't want to know.
So I don't need
this to be sorted.
Yeah, so there's
a 0, a minus 31.
So the key is that
I've discovered this.
And everything to the left
of that is less than 1.
And everything to the right
of that is greater than 1.
And that's the only
requirement that I have.
And as I said, I mean, I
said this to begin with
and then I forgot, I
said we're not going
to worry about the recursion.
So clearly, I have
to do more work here
with respect to taking
this set of numbers
and sorting them in
ascending order, et cetera.
But what I've done here is I
know that 1 is fixed in place,
and 1 will never move.
And I just have to turn
this into minus 31 and 0.
And I have to do
some reordering here.
But 1 is fixed in place.
Now, the algorithm that
I'm going to show you,
I'm going to show you the code.
And it's probably
code that you won't
be able to parse, at least
in minutes or seconds.
And this code is
in place pivoting.
It's clever code.
And what it does is it has
one additional variable
worth of storage that we're
going to call the pivot.
So you see the
variable pivot there.
And just using that one
additional integer storage,
it manages to transform this
array using a linear number
of steps into this array.
So you can see that
this is non-trivial.
And I need to move from
here to there without having
this extra storage.
If you had extra storage,
it would be easy.
We know how to do that.
But if you didn't,
you need this code
that has an outer while loop.
You see while not done.
And then it's got two
inner while loops in it.
And it's got a couple of
counters, couple of pointers
I should say, to indices.
And you go left and right, and
you magically get this answer.
But there's no magic here,
because we have the code up
and we can run it.
And computers aren't
smart, so clearly,
that code is doing
something clever,
and we just need to
understand that, all right?
So I'm going to--
in the couple of
minutes I have left,
this is the last
thing I want to do
is I want to tell you
how this code works.
And it's really pretty code.
And it's clever code.
So what I have is I have two
pointers, top and bottom.
So I'm going to, essentially,
say that top is--
bottom is 0.
Initially, it's minus 1, but
we go ahead and increment it.
And top is 8.
And so how many--
I have 9-- 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
So top is pointing to the pivot.
So this is pointing to
pivot, which top is 8.
And bottom is pointing
to the first element.
So these two while
loops are essentially
going from the left of the
array and going this way
from the right of the array.
So what we're going to do--
and don't worry about exactly
how the code does this.
I'm going to show you the
way this array is transformed
and the way these
pointers are changed.
And then you'll get a sense
of how this code works.
And obviously,
this transformation
happens in one of
those while loops.
So we have the pivot
corresponding to 1.
And bottom equals
0 and top equals 8.
What I'm going to
do is I'm going
to start moving leftward from--
this would be the
second inner while loop.
I'm going to start moving--
oh, I'm sorry.
I'll start with bottom.
I'm going to increment--
bottom is initially minus 1.
I increment it to 0.
And I start moving rightward
from the left of the list
and try and find an element
that is greater than 1.
And that is immediate.
I realize that 4 is
greater than 1, OK?
So when I realize that
4 is greater than 1,
I'm going to copy over 4.
And this is doesn't mean that
I'm copying the entire array.
I'm just going to copy over 4.
But I'm writing what the array
looks like, because that's
important, over to here.
And you might say--
pivot equals 1.
You might say, oh, but I
overwrote the location 1.
And I'm like, don't
worry about it.
I do have 1 stored in my pivot.
So my pivot has 1 in it.
So I haven't lost anything here.
It's not like I threw
away any locations.
I do have that extra location.
So I did this rightward
move going from the left.
Now I'm going to go
leftward from the right.
And I'm going to look for
something that is less than 1
and I'm going to
try and move it.
So basically, what
this algorithm does
is it tries to find
things that are--
if a is greater than g, it
moves a to the rightmost part
of the array.
And the same thing,
if d is less than g,
then it moves it to the
left part of the array.
So depending on whether
the comparison to g
is greater or less,
you want to end up
in the edges of the array.
And you're going to try and
get the edges of the array
to be correct in the sense
that they have elements
on the left that are
less than the pivot,
and the elements
on the right that
are greater than the pivot.
And you're trying to
get to the middle.
And when your two
pointers converge,
your top and bottom pointers
converge, you're done.
So let's do a couple more
steps and close this lecture.
So I did the right step.
Now I'm going rightward.
And now I'm going
to go leftward.
What is the first element
that is less than 1--
no, less, than 1.
0, right?
Yes, but I'm going this way.
AUDIENCE: oh!
SRINI DEVADAS: Yeah, I'm going--
I'm glad you pointed that out.
I needed to make sure.
So I went rightward
the first time,
and I want to go
leftward this time.
So this would be-- so I
come here and I see 0.
When I see 0, what
I'm going to do
is I'm going to
transform the array.
I'll write this out to
make sure I get this right.
And so right now I have 4,
65 to minus 31, 0, et cetera.
And I'm going to go this
way, and I'm going to put--
when I see the 0, I'm going
to copy over 0 over here
and leave the 0 in
here for a second.
And there's no problem here,
because 4 was copied over here.
And so now I overwrote 4 with 0.
OK, now you kind of see,
maybe get some sense
of how this algorithm works.
This is the first interesting
step where I took 0,
and because 0 is less
than 1, as I mentioned,
I want to jam it all
the way to the left.
Just put it all the
way to the left.
And I'm cool with losing
4, because 4 is being put
all the way to the right, OK?
Now, at this point,
my bottom and top
are going to get modified.
My bottom is still
0, but the top is 4,
because I moved-- top was 8, and
I decremented top all the way
to the point where it became 4.
And I realized that
0 was less than 1.
And then I copied over that
value over to the bottom.
You can kind of see
the code up there.
This is actually an
output of that code.
And I put a 0 in here.
So that's what my
counters look like.
And it's only a
couple of more steps.
We're going to go now go right.
And I'm going to go do this
again, except that 0 is already
taken care of, so now I see 65.
Clearly I'm going to
have a situation where
if I go this way, 65 is
greater than the pivot,
so I'm going to go
0, 65, 2, minus 31.
And because 65 is
greater than the pivot,
I'm going to write it into what
the top was, which obviously
got copied over that way.
So I'm going to have 65 in
here, 99, 83, 782, and 4.
So now after this
step, bottom equals 1.
And the reason for that was
65 was in the location on 1,
and top equals 4.
And then the next
one, someone want
to tell me what the
next one is going to be?
If I go leftward.
I'm going to start
from here, top was 4.
So I was pointing at 65.
And I'm looking for something
that when I go this way,
I saw 65 greater than 1.
Now I'm looking for something
that is less than 1.
And minus 31 is less
than 1, correct?
When I go this way, I'm looking
for something that's less than.
So given that it's minus 31,
I'm going to copy over minus 31
to what top was pointing to.
So I have minus 31, 2, minus
31, 65, 99, 28, 782, and 4.
And at this point, I'm
going to have bottom
equals 1 and top equals 3.
Keep going one more, and I get
to the point where I see 2.
2 is greater than 1.
0 and minus 31 are less than 1.
And so I take 2 and
I copy it over here.
And now at this point,
when I do an increment,
I realize that bottom
is 2 and top is 3.
And in the very next step,
bottom will equal top.
And I'm sitting up
here, and so I copy--
I make two--
I'd write the pivot
into the location that
corresponds to the bottom
after top got decremented.
And in that case, both
bottom and top are 2.
And that index, 0, 1, and 2,
the pivot gets written into it.
And so that's
exactly what I had,
which I wrote right
at the beginning.
So I would say this is probably
the most complicated code
from a control flow standpoint
that I've ever shown you.
This algorithm is an in
place algorithm that does not
require any extra storage.
And that's exactly
why it's so popular.
People are sorting billions
of elements in lists,
and you can't use
gigabytes of storage
during the sorting process.
And what this clever
strategy tells you is you
don't need all of that storage.
You can do things in place.
And as long as you choose
the pivot reasonably well,
you get your average
case N log N complexity,
which is the same as the worst
case complexity of mergesort.
So you've got to be a little
bit careful with that.